you look at an animation show like a
show like on cartoon network on adult
swim
it takes uh the network about anywhere
between 500 and 700
000 per episode to produce
and it takes a very long time
[Music]
amit tischler thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
finally it's an honor to have you yeah
thank you so much
happy to be here animations
graphic design technology startups
gaming
you know we have so much to talk about
because i know nothing
about the work the fascinating work that
you're doing amit
first of all who are you because you're
not just the typical
entrepreneur are you probably not uh
the question who are you like man that
is a big one
am i really the one to define that it's
philosophical
well okay let me try and summarize the
weird
uh history of my life i suppose or my
career please
um so i actually started i think like
you said i'm
not exactly the boilerplate entrepreneur
um
in terms of my story and my career
progression
i started off from 2d animation so
i studied hand-drawn animation we're
talking light tables
pencils um that was the first medium
i've ever practiced in
uh and i studied in israel i'm
originally from
tel aviv i guess in that regard
i am kind of like fitting within the
entrepreneur box like i'm from tel aviv
that's a good start um
but yeah i studied through the animation
and
um in my first few years i've uh worked
in israel just like in the industry
essentially gaining experience in the
field itself
i was always where the spirit of
entrepreneurship
was always there is that i did always
want to
do my own thing um if anything
i think i can safely say that i've been
very opinionated
about my taste about how i think
things should work whether uh on an
industry level or even on a
granular narrative level and uh
that really drove me forward because one
of my goals was i realized okay if i'm
gonna
stay in israel sure i'll be able to
continue working
but it's never going to take me one step
forward or one step beyond i always
wanted to get more into
the glass ceiling exactly kind of the
glass ceiling of just you know
being outside of where real
entertainment kind of comes from which
is
los angeles where i live in today um and
i knew that
i kind of had to be here to really get
things going especially because a lot of
my interest was in developing original
ip
now another really bizarre thing or i
don't know if it's that bizarre
i'm a big fan of everything i like like
i wear it on
myself like like armor uh
and i've always been a video game fan i
also worked as a video game
journalist early on uh in my career
ended up really drawing me back and
forth
between work on software whether it's
like educational or
game development um right to tv
animation
so i've always kind of skipped between
the two um
i moved to the states at around 10 years
ago
and i did my master's here and then
moved to california because i was like
all right if i want to work in animation
if i want to work in entertainment
this is the place you got to be here uh
and fun fact
before you move to the us you actually
helped me compete in a google for
doodle for google competition for i
think like israel's
60th anniversary and so so thank you for
taking the time to spend with you know
i of course i remember because i i i you
know i sent it and i i don't know if you
even know i sent it as if i did it
i didn't i just sat next to you while
you did
you just documented while crying sir
exactly amit before we continue you know
you're mentioning the animation space
graphic design space i know nothing
about this give me
the you know the three minute crash
course what is the animation
space what is the supply chain look like
what does an animator even do
in their day-to-day life that is a
fantastic question
and it's multi-layered and it actually
transitions really nicely into
how i started my company uh pop bass
with
lisa and richard perfect um so basically
like as an animator
even though you are essentially the
craft person making the show
uh whether it's 3d animation or 2d
animation you're the one moving the
characters animation is
in the end motion it's motion graphics
it's more specifically
let's say character based motion
graphics is the best way to kind of uh
define it as opposed to just standard
like motion graphics that are more
graphic design based
um and in the end of the day
this is a massive massive industry
that is cross-generational that's
dealing with a lot of
creative ips i think one of the things
that
um i've seen both fascinate the tech
industry
and also really confuse the tech
is a entertainment seems to have
a really massive blind spot when it
comes down to integrating technology
right into its pipelines these are
actually really old programming
pipelines
as an animator you come in and you work
within the studio system right so by the
time that you come
in the process has already been through
um you know
a show has been pitched that's your
concept uh the show has been
developed and there are multiple steps
in the process whether it went through a
network or the studio system it actually
right it's incredibly complicated and
then by the end of it when it actually
gets green light into production
you're starting with pre-production
you're bringing in your screenwriters
then you're bringing in your storyboard
artists your designers
at some point while production is
already running you have a channel that
it's going to be on or you know what
your distribution is
um at that point the animator comes in
you already have all of your guidelines
right you're part of an animation team
uh usually working hand to hand with
pre-production and post-production
in the end the show appears on
television that's as simple as that
right right so animators in many ways
are as creative as they are they are a
cog in the machine
um where the top of the hierarchy are
always
the networks because they are primarily
distribution channels
but many times not always they're also
the ip owners
so when you think of cross-generational
properties like star wars
for example right um this is an
intellectual property and once again
intellectual property in the world of
tech
and i've seen this multiple times when
talking to vcs it means something very
different
so they're thinking of technological uh
intellectual property
and when you're talking about
intellectual property in hollywood
very often or more often than not you
are referring to something like
star wars spider-man which is talking
about
um narrative driven intellectual
properties
and the amazing thing about those
intellectual properties
is that they very rarely if at all
become irrelevant
because and that's what i mean by
cross-generational uh and you can see
like hollywood marketing is very aware
of that so they make sure
now we're going to create the star wars
for the younger generation
right right and and this goes all the
way back to even fairy tales right
stuff that is currently public domain
because stories
are or good storytelling is immortal
right so in many ways if your
intellectual property
is a story and it has characters and
it's defined by those certain parameters
it's in as long as you own it it is
potentially immortal and it could be
applied
to games to television to
really any form of entertainment and
that's where the licensing business in
hollywood comes from
you're a developer you don't have your
own intellectual property but you say
hey you know what um if i have the
license for spider-man
i can make an amazing spider-man game
and i can monetize the living hell
out of it well if you have enough
capital to to basically give to at this
point
disney to license out the ip and they
approve it now you get to monetize on
their intellectual property which means
they get part of the revenue you get
part of revenue still a standard
licensing model but once again the
thinking is
really all around the narrative
right and that's interesting yeah that's
how they define the intellectual
property that's of
the highest value in hollywood for me i
came from again
from animation to ip development i
started pitching original ips to
networks i started selling and optioning
on
shows to tv networks and getting in
front of that pipeline
and when you're there you get to see a
what they're looking for and b also what
they're thinking about
in terms of how to immortalize their own
brands
because if you think of a tv network
they can have like a lot of different tv
shows
but in the end they are trying if they
are a good brand
they're trying to define themselves like
we are the brand that
makes um shows of this kind we're
telling these kinds of stories we have a
style we have a
disney has been teaching everybody how
to do that
um while incorporating other brands
underneath its umbrella right they are
basically the crown jewel of uh the
industry in that regard
both the crown jewel and the death star
right so
you can define it whichever way you want
but um
when we looked at that we realized that
one of the weaknesses and that
goes all the way back to um hollywood's
weakness as opposed
like when it comes to integrating new
pipelines
or technology pipelines is that
everything is really siloed
it is an incredibly siloed industry
uh their relationship their fascination
with the industry of like video games
which is one of the
fastest growing um like branches of
entertainment
currently out there uh has been
it kind of goes both ways with the video
game industry
obviously having interest in hollywood's
big ips because that's what inspired a
lot of
video game developers to create what
they're doing but also hollywood's
like uh fascination with anything that
is
a little bit more sci-fi this is
interactive they know that it's the
future
but they're also afraid of it because
they don't fully understand it
and they don't know how to handle it
which was why a lot of big businesses
like universal and disney
even recently said we're not going to
try and develop our own things anymore
we're just going to go into a licensing
model so if you want to make games based
on our ideas just
go right ahead uh i didn't know all this
yeah so interesting
so there's and again this has been
evolving over the years and it's been
going back and forth like if you think
of disney as an entity
their department of disney interactive
has shut down and reopened
about like three four times in the last
10 to 15 years that's how fast this is
moving
of how they decide where their new
agenda is
uh but what was very clear to us is that
um
as a society and i don't think that this
is a controversial statement at this
point
uh we have a communication problem right
and it's whether you're trying to
educate
people whether you're trying to
entertain them whether you're trying to
market to them
or if you're just trying to explain to
people that the world isn't flat in the
year 2020 for some reason
um you essentially have to have three
key elements in order to really cut
through the noise right now
you need to have uh you know the the
long and short form storytelling
abilities of essentially hollywood of of
shows of netflix of streaming media you
need to have the interactivity of video
games because that
really enhances knowledge retention and
of course when you look at the younger
generation
this is one of the main forms of
communication they consume
in multiple different ways and you also
need to have and this is
really key you need to have the
flexibility and the speed of response of
social media right yes
a tweet comes out and exposes itself
uh to so many people so much faster than
an entity even as powerful as
disney can respond right
so it's so much easier to get bad
information out there
uh and much much faster than getting
good vetted information that is
controlled by you to your audience
and part of it is right is just that
pipeline if you think about
creating an animated show right and this
is where
my experience comes in in this company
because our entire
um our entire agenda and what our
technology does
is take those three things right the um
fast flexibility and response time of
social media those
basically social media marketing
practices interactivity of video games
and the ability to tell an ongoing
linear story
right takes these three things kills
them in one stone and essentially build
an infrastructure
that puts them all through one ecosystem
which is incredibly powerful
it has taken us years to actually
develop something that can work
um but the idea is really to be able to
create a form of communication that is
sustainable
that is future proof and we just believe
that it's kind of inevitable
right you're looking at it i have to say
i mean you know
you were talking about you know pop base
and then the the journey that you've
gone through and i have to say you know
obviously i've seen the product and the
way that you're
describing it as is you know a
communication tool and future proof and
and and you know that whole vertical of
this
integrated communication that you know
is not really
understandable for somebody coming from
from you know both from a different
generation even i'm
considering myself as an older
generation from this because uh
you know i'm getting and producing
information very differently
in the way that for example my nieces do
right but but i think that what you're
doing with paw base
is really fascinating and i'd love for
you to share with me a little bit about
what you're
tangibly doing what is spa based what is
the technology that you're building and
what is the future that you
envision with podbase as an integral
part of every kid's
i guess daily routine as they go through
learning and developing habits
that's a fantastic question so let me
try and uh give you
the aspirational part of the pitch it
will maybe help illustrate
um what it is we're aiming for so if you
can imagine
um let's say a netflix cartoon an
animated show
that also plays like an open world video
game right like a zelda world of
warcraft
uh but has the ability to update its
content and be as responsive
as a social media brand that's
essentially
the technology that pop base built it is
a cms
so it's a web portal that allows us to
control
a creative ip within an ecosystem on any
screen now
i'll illustrate that for you right so
our go to market strategy right now
we're basically we build this technology
we're like we know this works we know
this is fantastic we know we can drive
these
incredibly immersive story driven
experiences and really just control the
virtual world
um through a live ops dashboard in a way
that isn't loose
um and what i mean by isn't loose it's
not a creator platform
which is what a lot of the focus of
let's say social media companies have
been currently like
how do we make sure that anyone can just
tell any story
okay right but that isn't usually not
the tool that a large brand let's say
like
disney can use in the same extent right
sure they can distribute stuff on
youtube and now you're on the same
playing field as everybody else it's not
it doesn't really immerse you in the
world it doesn't allow you to control
the whole thing you're still relying on
a separate ecosystem
so what we're doing is that we're
launching through
um a uh the wellness market right which
is a
right full of white space it's got like
575 billion dollar
uh market right now where most of the
apps that
um kids are given are either
mini games or they're kind of like they
have the fitbit approach of like i'm
giving you an interactive task list
that's gamified
and what works but what is the problem i
mean what what is the problem of the
wellness space why
is there so much money that is being
poured in you know you this is an
extraordinary amount of money that any
startup would love to say they're in
a multi-hundred billion dollar space i
would never
imagine that the wellness communication
space is that big what what is what's
going on there
look at where we live right now the
times of coven
and this is exactly the point of why
we're saying we have a communication
problem
right we're right just the idea right
teaching people hey
wear a mask when you go outside because
this is what happened wash your hands
right basic hygiene basic safety things
that you think
people should know or should learn
through schools or should learn
through um really anywhere
but right now when somebody like if the
uh fda tweets something
and if the president tweets something
and if a troll tweets something
it's flat it's the same amount of noise
right it's really hard for people to
source out what's real and what's not
and they need
something trusted now for us we're
saying we're trying to get to a
generation that's early like our
go to market focuses on children that
are ages four to six
and part of the idea is well this is a
generation that's growing
watching netflix scrubbing on tick tock
playing video games like fortnite
you can't give them interactive task
list apps or give them pamphlets and
expect them like yeah they're going to
retain this information
if the teacher comes in and goes like
wash your hands kids
they're gonna go yeah okay who cares
right you can't do that but we come from
entertainment
and we know that one of the most
powerful things you could do
is it kind of it has to come from
intrinsic motivation
right so right you have to want to
engage with something and learn from it
so many people talk about how um you
know a certain
let's say movie has made them feel
something or gave them the power to
apply what they've learned from it it
sounds kind of silly but it really isn't
these are stories that inspire you
and we want to create an immersive
experience that is essentially
speaking their language because it's
quick it's responsive it's immersive it
feels like you're going into a magical
world
you don't know you're there to learn
it's more like dora the explorer sesame
street
when you as a kid watch sesame street
you don't think you're watching
something educational
as an adult you go oh okay the count
was teaching me how to oh i see but you
don't think of that as a kid because
you're too busy being embraced in the
world and entertained
we're saying right we're creating a
virtual world
where every feature is something we can
control and change
on a minute so in a moment's notice
through our dashboard in order to be
able to respond to
how people behave with it in order to
actually talk directly to our audience
without even knowing
who each person is you think of dora the
explorer they always have these segments
where you know uh and
it's very sweet and i get where it's
coming from but it's also kind of
awkward that dora kind of turns to the
camera and goes like
well kids what do you think right
length and i'm like you assume that they
respond you piloted it but you can't
really track something like that
we're actually telling kids no you need
to respond we'll know it
right you're actually speaking to the
character and we will
i think that i have to say i mean one of
the things that i i have to mention here
because i think
you know on one hand creating content
that is interactive and is
producing the same effect and i think
it's incredible but
building an infrastructure that allows
others to come and modify that content
to fit their own specific needs right
every school wants to tell their story a
little bit different
every you know place that needs to teach
about how to deal with an
earthquake needs to be in a little bit
of a different situation different
communication you know
we're looking at a globalized world
we're still
you know a million different cultures
you know even within the us we have
different cultures and different ways of
communication
and having a team of animators building
one product with one communication
that targets all just doesn't work
especially not for kids
and i think that what you're doing with
with paw base beyond
you know the the actual you know
messaging of of one game but actually
building the infrastructure
that allows other creators to go and
modify that i think that's really the
the innovative part here that i as a
technologist and you know as a startup
enthusiast i'm really excited about
yeah thank you and and the interesting
thing is the way that we're thinking
about it
and again we'll see where the market
actually takes us but
um right now the way that we're
launching is that we're launching our
own original ip because once again we're
going this way right late value
um and we get to gather our own team of
experts to say
we have a showrunner an actual hollywood
show runner like he's going to help us
dictate the content he's going to rely
on their knowledge but like you said
he's going to work with schools he's
going to work with hospitals that
essentially tell them like
a segment of our audience we want to get
them this information can we get this
just
absolutely the system allows you to do
that it allows you to also distribute it
um
publicly now what it also allows to do
and that's what we're really hoping
because that's the um
let's say woodland mystery is the
product that we're launching on the
system as you know it's a railway system
and this is the first product we're kind
of tossing on it because again
area full of white space it's a good way
to break into uh the market
but what we're saying is okay
on one hand you could have the 100
million dollar business of
woodland mysteries does really well and
now the kids are growing out of it
make your new ip right make another one
for kids five to eight make another one
so kids grow up
it's great we will be delighted that's
like having your own proprietary tool
that gives you that advantage
the other thing you touched on that's
the multi-billion dollar business
right and it's something that we're
optimizing for which is the minute you
put it out there our tool
doesn't only solve the communication
problem it's also a it's a pipeline tool
that comes from
again thinking of animation our founding
team comes from i come from television
my ceo and cto both come from long
long history of video game development
on both engineering and the technical
art side
and that's what we really combine our
thinking with like this is how hollywood
handles things and this is how video
games handle things uh
just as a side note video game the video
game industry
has been so far ahead on
so many technologies and i think now the
tech world is starting to catch up to it
because they're going like oh my god
look at
why is this so successful how are they
doing these things in terms of r d
they are so far ahead you have no idea
like i encourage vcs to look more and
more
into the video game industry because a
lot of the tech companies right now that
are considered disruptive
really seem to them like primitive at
this point right
so when you look at all of these
pipelines we're essentially saying
and this is an interesting piece of
information regardless but when you look
at an
animation show like a show like on
cartoon network on adult swim
it takes uh the network about anywhere
between 500 to 700
000 per episode to produce and it takes
a
very long time you think of the length
of a season on netflix it's like
uh eight episodes per season the
traditional yeah is more like 11 minutes
20 episodes per season it takes years
from when you actually start
pre-production
to unbelievable and even the production
of an episode itself takes
months we essentially build a tool
that allows us to distribute the same
length like a
half hour fully interactive fully
immersive
piece of content an episode with a team
of like
five to six people in two weeks so
going back to what this model does if we
put it out there and it gets very
quickly validated
our hope is you know someone like a
disney like a cartoon network which we
have worked with before
looks at this and goes wait a minute
you've done what can i use that
can i essentially use my own
intellectual property to communicate my
message
it could be purely entertainment amazing
it can be education but i want to do
this
there you go here's our api you are our
developer tools and here's all the
documentation
now you have the power to do the same
thing and that's what we're really
hoping for and that's what we're
optimizing the entire business around
but you know it's a it's a journey
i made a wonderful and you know beyond
everything beyond the technology and the
animation in the industry i think that
the fact that the fact that what you're
working on really at the end of the day
it's in the wellness space and
and the positive impact it's going to
have and the butterfly effect that it's
going to have is just tremendous
that's what really i'm excited about you
know from the sidelines but it's a
really
amazing job and it's really really
inspiring to to
get to know these new industries and
these new passions and and
and watching somebody growing up with a
certain passion and following it through
both relocating and moving through
different journeys but now
working on puppies for quite some time
now and being so passionate about it
honestly that's that's one of the most
inspiring things here before we leave
out to
uh ask you for the most important
question which is three words that you
would use to describe yourself
okay um i would say
determined i would say direct
i would say loud and you can interpret
that
in any way you want i i love all those
amit thank you so so much
best of luck with pop bass and and i
can't wait to see where this thing is
going thank you
thank you